bonjour à tous je suis sé le tchtech le
Sénat est-ce que ça vous parle
aujourd'hui je vous explique ce que
c'est alors le Sénat c'est quoi France
il existe deux assemblées l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat elle forment le
Parlement les sénateurs siègent et
travaille dans le palais du Luxembourg à
Paris en France de qui est composé le
Sénat le Sénat est composé de 348
sénateur élu pour 6 ans et d'un
président élu pour 3 ans ce sont des
femmes et des hommes comme tout le monde
avant d'être sénateur ils ont exercer
différents
métiers d'après les statistiques il y a
au Sénat 5,5% d'agriculteurs 26 %
d'enseignants 7 % de commerçants ou de
chefs d'entreprise bien souvent les
sénateurs sont déjà Mair élus de leur
département ou de leur région parmi eux
132 sont maires 109 sont conseillers
généraux et 26 sont conseillers
régionaux la moyenne d'âge des sénateurs
est de 65
ans mais par qui sont-ils élus les
sénateurs sont élus au suffrage
universel indirect c'est-à-dire qu'ils
ne sont pas élus directement par les
Français mais par environ 150000 grands
électeurs ce sont les maires les
conseillers municipaux et les
députés qui sont les sénateurs de la
Réunion les sénateurs de la Réunion sont
Didier Robert Michel Fontaine Michel
Vergo et Paul
vergess à quoi sert le Sénat le rôle du
Parlement est de discuter et de voter
les lois chaque loi est examinée par le
Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale le Sénat comme l'Assemblée
nationale peut aussi contrôler les
actions du gouvernement il peut poser
des questions aux ministres sur leur
politique mais à la différence de
l'Assemblée nationale le Sénat défend en
plus les intérêts des communes des
départements et des régions ce qu'on
appelle les collectivité
territoriale le Sénat peut aussi
modifier la Constitution avec
l'Assemblée nationale dans ce cas ils se
réunissent à versaill en congrès la
Constitution
c'est l'ensemble des règles suprêmes de
fonctionnement d'un pays en France quand
on change de constitution on change le
numéro de la République depuis la
Constitution de 1958 nous sommes dans la
5e République et concrètement que fait
le Sénat par exemple face au risque pour
l'environnement le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale ont adopté une loi interdisant
le maïs génétiquement modifi car il peut
présenter des risques pour
l'environnement et la
santé vous l'aurez compris le Sénat est
une institution importante je vous dis à
bientôt dans un nouvel
épisode